desde human rigths watch una alerta
urgente sobre las protestas en colombia
hemos corroborado el uso de tanquetas
con lanzadores de proyectiles múltiples
dirigidos a manifestantes es un arma
peligrosa e indiscriminada el ministerio
de defensa debe dar explicaciones
son imágenes que parecen una escena de
guerra y no de protesta y es que en
colombia la policía nacional depende del
ministerio de defensa y no del interior
una anomalía en la mayoría de gobiernos
por eso el entrenamiento que recibe es
de carácter militar
esto se traduce en números entre 2017 y
2019 la policía cometió 289 homicidios
casi el mismo número que el ejército
la ong temblores registró casi 40 mil
casos de violencia física 1100 cada mes
y 102 casos de violencia sexual casi 3
al mes
durante la última semana de
manifestaciones en colombia el escuadrón
antidisturbios llamado smart está en el
punto de mira de las acusaciones de
muertes en las protestas y no es la
primera vez este escuadrón creado en
1999 de manera temporal se estableció
como una unidad policial con formación
antisubversiva y desde su creación hasta
2019 se le atribuyen 43 de ejecuciones
extrajudiciales
las últimas movilizaciones de colombia
no han sido la excepción en septiembre
de 2020 un hombre que rompía las reglas
del confinamiento perdió la vida a manos
de la policía un hecho que desató
protestas masivas y que terminaron con
13 muertes más por parte de los
uniformados mientras que en el paro
nacional de noviembre de 2019 el smac
disparó un proyectil contra el joven
dylan cruz y lo mató un evento que
conmocionó al país
un país que todavía no sabía que en el
siguiente paro nacional las muertes se
contarían por decenas